when boris johnson lifted the national
lockdown in july
he made a promise to the doubters one he
perhaps hoped he'd never have to keep
let me reassure them and reassure you
that we will not hesitate at any stage
to put on the brakes now the virus is
moving fast and this week the pm will
put his foot down
using his scientific advisors to prepare
the ground
for a tightening of restrictions once
more but this time around he has a much
harder task
to persuade the public his party and
even his own cabinet
to follow his lead in the commons
there is resistance but facing mps today
the health secretary warning action
needs to be taken
but now as the virus is spreading once
more we have had to act
for now that means a toughening of local
lockdown rules in parts of the midlands
and the north west
but more national restrictions are
expected
i've set out today the measures the
government is taking so far
we're working right now on what further
measures may be necessary
and the prime minister will update the
house tomorrow with any more action
that we need to take but some in his
party have had enough
have been told what to do and are
demanding they're given a bigger role to
play
you've got ministers who now for six
months have been
governing by decree in relation to the
handling of the coronavirus
pandemic we're in a very different place
now and six months on it really is time
the ministers recognized
that they need to involve parliament
but a bigger role for parliament in
england could slow down decisions
and nicola sturgeon is clear scotland
won't be waiting for westminster
i need to be absolutely straight with
people across scotland that additional
restrictions will almost certainly be
put in place
in scotland over the next couple of days
hopefully this will be with four nations
alignment but if necessary it will have
to happen
without that no waiting for alignment in
northern ireland
arlene foster announcing the
introduction of national measures
from tomorrow evening for every home
across northern ireland there will be
no mixing of households indoors
with exemptions for bubbling with one
other household
locked in number 10 with his closest
advisors
the prime minister is now facing very
difficult judgment calls
about how to deal with the second wave
of coronavirus and what measures
he should put in place to try to stem
the tide
he has to weigh up the public health
risk against the political and economic
fallout
of an even partial lockdown of the
country
or the economy and the backlash is
building
from a weary public and restive mps
tomorrow boris johnson will chair an
emergency cobra meeting with leaders and
health officials from across
the uk as well as a meeting with his
cabinet as he signs off a plan of action
he's decided he needs to do more to
tackle the spread of this virus
but his plan will only work if he can
get us all to follow it
beth rigby sky news westminster